[Music]
this is the workforce of the future
technology is transforming the world of
work beyond all recognition
creating groundbreaking opportunities
it's an amazing thing to be living in
this digital age but it's also eroding
the rights of workers it creates kind of
dog-eat-dog world some even fear a
dystopian jobless future technology
today could lead to 45% of current jobs
disappearing but are these anxieties
overblown the future is about the
collaboration between humans and these
technologies how we react to this brave
new world of work today will shape
societies for generations to come
[Music]
[Music]
for some people work is where the Wi-Fi
is
in the past two years Samantha and
Justin have lived and worked in more
than 20 countries we started this year
in South America we lived in Peru in
Santiago Chile
barolay Argentina Croatia Innsbruck
Austria Portugal Italy Norway which was
really pretty and then we're on Reunion
Island for two month off of Madagascar
yes
and when we were there everyone was like
how in the world did you how did you
find this place but throughout their
travels Justin and Samantha have each
been holding down a job
he runs a digital creative agency and
she works for a california-based
start-up there are very modern
incarnation of a very old idea they're
digital nomads thank you
today people working remotely around the
globe like this number in the millions a
lot of people that define themselves as
digital nomads move around very very
frequently but we typically move around
at least once a month the couple say the
extraordinary recent advances in digital
technology allow them to keep exploring
the world without compromising their
careers we rent an apartment we set up
an office we're not on vacation we live
pretty normal lives and so it gives us
the opportunity to kind of integrate and
become locals and try on different
flavors of life there are downsides to
this liberating Grand Tour of new
cultures and horizons digital nomads
sometimes have to be more nomadic than
they might like just out of curiosity I
wonder what the visa policy is location
independent workers as they're also
known often travel on tourist visas and
are usually restricted to a maximum of a
few months in each country so Fuji we
need to go to so that we can get out of
New Zealand yeah well we violate their
visa policy yeah
but some countries are going out of
their way to attract this new breed of
global worker Estonia is about to launch
a special visa allowing them to stay for
a year with other countries set to
follow suit some predict there could be
a billion location-independent workers
by 2035 for those with no ties it all
points to an increasingly borderless
brave new world of work centered around
the digital revolution and it sounds
extravagant but we don't need much to be
able to work and be productive if you're
smart about it I think that travel can
be a long-term sustainable lifestyle and
it's not that crazy after more than 60
million Americans who work over 50
million are employees
they work for somebody else in the
middle of the 20th century many workers
in the rich world expected a job for
life in one place but today frequent job
changes are not unusual and 70% of
professionals around the globe do some
work remotely these seismic changes are
leading to continual reinventions of
that most traditional workplace the
office in San Francisco entrepreneur
Frank boulier is starting his daily
journey to work you have to move from my
room go down the stairs to my off space
I would say it's a dream commute yeah
Frank's part of an emerging trend living
and working with other people in the
same place when I moved from one space
to the other space I switch from living
to working the space run by a company
called Rome includes meeting rooms
relaxation areas and even a cocktail bar
it caters to the more exclusive end of
the global co-working market
you get to meet amazing people from all
across the world and find that exciting
the vibe is less office more
professional commune and the residents
are glad of the chance for some digital
detox we're all cell phones other to
technology and I think that what do you
make about Rome is that it builds
community and it builds a communal
living style that allows that sort of to
unplug at times this kind of communal
living might have niche appeal right now
but 2.3 million people worldwide already
share co-working spaces and there are
signs these make for more productive
workers the Harvard Business Review
found that nearly nine out of ten
co-workers felt happier than in their
previous place of work and over 80
percent felt more engaged and motivated
I've never been more productive like
even though I do less hours whatever I
go back to traditional corporate
nine-to-five no technology is also
changing how people work in live in
poorer countries
Kabira Kenya Africa's largest slum work
here is scarce the average wage is less
than $2 a day
Joseph Kemal grew up here this is my
first computer two years ago he was
scraping by as a street hawkers selling
food but today Joseph is making a new
living as a paid-up member of the global
gig economy the labor market where
self-employed workers are paid to do
short-term freelance tasks for me a
person living here in Kibera how would I
have gotten a job for a person in
America he gets up to ten part-time jobs
a week entering data for clients based
all around the world it's an amazing
thing to be living in this digital age
Joseph works in arguably the fastest
growing segment of the gig economy known
as a human cloud some of the jobs that
used to be done by white-collar workers
in wealthier countries are now broken
down into individual tasks these are
advertised online and carried out by
remote workers scattered across the
globe this human cloud industry is worth
an estimated 50 billion dollars a year
now the Kenyan government is training 1
million young people for this new
digital workforce and helping them is
the outsourcing firm samasource plans
are they included Google eBay and
Microsoft freelancers here work on a
range of digital services including
image tagging for artificial
intelligence we're training close to
drove themselves we are working on
projects on the South some fear that the
flow of digital service jobs from rich
countries to poorer ones could push down
wages globally but for many people here
the new opportunities offer a way out of
poverty I know someone sitting in the US
might say you know a job like this is
not paying a living wage but for us it
really gives us an opportunity to be
able to bring some of these young people
into digital age and the digital economy
since working in the human cloud joseph
has been able to move his family out of
the slum I'm gonna join University next
semester I'm gonna do computer science
my dream cause
[Music]
in wealthier countries some workers see
the gig economy as less of an
opportunity and more of a threat Max
Dewhurst is a delivery cyclist for a
British courier firm who campaigns for
workers rights how many jobs am I gonna
do today am I gonna do 18 jobs or 30
jobs on days when it's very slow we're
not going to make enough money to live
many online platforms those
intermediaries between customers and gig
workers don't cap the number of
freelancers that clock on each day this
can flood the market ramping up
competition and slashing earnings it
creates kind of dog-eat-dog world and a
very competitive world amongst the
workforce some competition amongst
workers is healthy for consumers but Max
has a more fundamental complaint the
basic employment rights such as sick pay
and job protection are denied to most
gig economy workers they don't have any
ability to set the price of their labor
they don't have any ability to negotiate
with the client they have zero
protection of course people like
flexibility but that shouldn't come at
the expense of everything that's ever
been fought for for the last 200 years
[Music]
[Applause]
max continues that fight as vice
president of the independent Workers
Union of Great Britain
[Music]
the union is mounting legal challenges
against large companies operating in the
gig economy we've taken a number of
career companies to tribunal and City
Spring II Korea Addison Lee and Excel
and now we're taking on delivery as well
to critics like Max the lack of rights
offered to workers in the gig economy by
big contractors is rapacious capitalism
that will increase inequality there are
the loads and those are people on these
bogus contracts we see it more and more
spreading into other sectors cleaning
retail banking and that's very worrying
amid heightened concerns about job
security some workers are facing new
pressures to become more efficient and
productive but what lumps is it
acceptable for companies to go to to
achieve this in Boston Massachusetts
workers at this firm are being closely
watched their every conversation is
analyzed their every move monitored this
is our humanized symmetric badge their
employer humanise has designed
surveillance technology to gather data
about how they spend their time at work
so it knows if I'm speaking or not
speaking and it knows if I'm moving
whether I'm walking around or just
sitting at my desk during the day it
knows generally where I am in the office
and it also can tell my proximity to
other people wearing badges
information from employees emails and
calendars is integrated with data
collected by their badges we have a
number of sensors in them bluetooth
that's able to do
location the office microphones look at
how much I caught motion sensor to look
at posture overall activity levels the
company says it uses this data to
improve the productivity of its workers
and their work environment I see
interactions within my team how many of
my teammates did I interact with in a
week or a month the same gender or the
other gender I can see my dominance in
conversation the green is my speaking
time versus the blue which is and I'm
listening I use this data as a way to
optimize my work experience humanize
cells its surveillance technology to
companies around the globe and with more
than ten thousand people now wearing its
badges worldwide business is starting to
boom because now we have all this
quantitative data coming in we're able
to understand at an unprecedented level
this kind of surveillance technology is
raising fears about workers welfare and
rights to privacy a British report found
that 70 percent of workers believe
workplace monitoring will become more
common in the future over 60 percent
believe it will fuel distrust and
discrimination
humanized says it anonymizes and
aggregates data and doesn't record the
content of conversations but other tech
companies are developing ever more
intrusive ways to monitor work forces
including microchipping staff and
photographing them at their desks using
webcams
[Music]
I mean there's legitimate concerns
around this kind of data when it comes
to it for example could your boss look
at what you're doing
minute by minute in the organization can
they look at what you're writing in
emails and things like that at some
point someone will do the wrong thing
with this kind of data but in the minds
of many people there's an even greater
threat to the workforce of the future
and it comes from a new breed of worker
one that is relentlessly efficient works
round the clock and never complains
robots and artificial intelligence are
increasingly part of many industries
machines will soon take the wheel from
truck drivers and companies are turning
to new types of robots for mass
production of food new worries about
robots taking jobs Automation is set to
cause mass disruption to working lives
as artificial intelligence and
automation grow by leaps and bounds
could lead to 45% of current jobs
disappearing but how justified is this
wave of automation anxiety sweeping
across the world are hundreds of
millions of workers really heading for a
jobless future
[Music]
in a warehouse in southern England the
dystopian vision of a fully automated
future appears to have arrived this
swarm of robots is packing groceries for
British firm Accardo one of the world's
most technologically advanced online
retailers here collaboration is key
these robots are being orchestrated by a
sophisticated piece of machine learning
it's a bit like an air traffic control
system they collaborate with one another
so if a robot wants to pick a bin that's
fourth down in a given stack of bins it
just gets three of its friends or
colleagues to move the top three bins
out of the way and then it grabs the one
it wants but the robots here aren't
working together to replace humans
they're working with them the robots
take containers of products to pick
stations where people put the orders
together I think the job is a lot less
taxing than us physically the robots
themselves are very efficient so they
take a lot of the grunt work out there
there are little helpers what's more a
card oh say these robots have actually
created more jobs at the company than
existed before
none of the 13,000 people that work for
Accardo would have a job myself included
if it wasn't for what we do with
technology and automation as we've found
new ways to automate processes a number
of people working for a card over has
only ever increased because the ongoing
growth of the business a growing body of
research suggests artificial
intelligence and machines could create
at least as many jobs as they displace
one report estimates that while 75
million jobs will be lost globally by
2022 there could be a hundred and thirty
three million new ones we are on a
journey to go on finding ways to add
automation but it's about teaching
people to be more adaptable in terms of
their jobs and their skill sets because
the future is about the collaboration
between humans and these technologies
disruption to working lives is
inevitable and insecurities will persist
how bosses workers and governments
respond to these challenges will
determine whether this new working
landscape lives up to its enormous
promise
[Music]
you